Let's review or summarize
everything we have learned about the plant
and animal cells. This to the left
is a drawing of an animal cage.
Animal cell.
And the one on the right is a drawing
of a plant cell.
Plant cell.
Let's start with
the outer part of the cage.
Both cell types have an extracellular matrix.
On the outside of the animal cage
you see all these collagen fibers and so on,
all these fibers hold the cell stable
allow cells to connect.
Depending on the exact composition of the extracellular matrix,
may also help in the transmission of signals between cells.
This is the extracellular matrix.
But when we talk about the extracellular matrix of
plant cell, we should also think about
some other components that
are part of the cell wall itself.
The cell wall is the main difference
between plant and animal cells.
The cell wall occurs in plant cells.
Animal cells have no cell walls.
If we go down one layer deeper, get to the plasma
membrane or cell membrane will
we see that it is present in both cell types.
The animal cell will have a cell membrane,
the plant cell will also have a cell membrane.
Both animals and plants can be seen
tunnels between adjacent cells,
the boundaries between two cells.
We studied them in the video about the cell wall of the plant cells.
We have seen that these things here are called plasmodeisms.
We can see a whole plasmode here,
where I started painting a part of the neighboring cage.
Plasmodems.
In animal cells analogous to plasmodezes are the socket contacts,
which are also tunnels between adjacent cells.
Clenched contacts.
Plasmodeisms are much more common in
different types of plants, compared to the slices of the animals.
Crowded contacts are common only in certain species
animal cells.
For example, adjacent cardiac muscle cells have socket contacts
with each other,
to allow the transmission of electrical signals through the heart tissue.
So the neighboring cells understand that they have to be shortened
in the right way. This is extremely important for
certain types of animal cells.
Now, let's go one more deeper layer.
But before that I want to say something again,
which I emphasize in almost every video.
All of these membranes we paint,
whether they are external cell membranes
or membrane organelles,
are double lipid layers, double phospholipid layers.
Let's increase this part here.
The yellow part
looks like a line,
but in reality
these are phospholipids,
these are double layers of phospholipids,
whose hydrophilic heads point outward,
and their hydrophobic tails point inward.
This double lipid layer extends along the entire membrane. Let it be clear.
All these membranes I paint
are double lipid layers.
Let's continue.
Once we enter the cell,
we see that both types of cells have a cytoskeleton.
We have cytoskeletons, therefore
here are microfilaments,
mycophilimate.
The drawing does not show their complex structure,
because we want to have a relatively simple one
cell diagram.
We have microtubules,
microtubules.
There may also be intermedia filaments.
We talk about all these structures in another video.
Now, let's pay more attention to other organelles.
Animal centers have centrosomes.
They are key to organizing microtubules.
We will talk a lot about centrosomes when dealing with mitosis.
We do not see centrosomes in plant cells.
Plant cells use other ways of organizing
of their microtubules,
especially during
mitosis. But let's see what other differences exist between the plant and the animal cage.
A big difference you can notice
is this big, blue balloon, like an egg.
These green things are not in it,
just the blue bubble is behind the green stuff.
Structures like this are associated with the plant, and with
animal cells.
This blue balloon is a central vacuum.
Central Vacuol.
The central vacuum can store liquids
or enzymes. It can also be considered as a waste disposal site.
In fact, although vacuoles are often found in plant cells,
they can have a variety of functions
depending on the type of plant cells.
I want you to pay attention to this,
we will talk about it and other videos.
We see all these organelles,
we make drawings, put them on charts
and we think we know what most of their functions are.
But in fact, organelles
cells as a whole are still subject to active scientific research.
In the coming decades we will find
many more features that these organelles can perform,
ways they can send signals and communicate,
what is their behavior under different conditions,
so we begin to understand
better what they do.
But in the coming decades we will learn more
much, much more about the different structures and functions
of the cage.
As I already mentioned, this is the central vacuum.
It is large and can provide structural support
of the cage, can store things,
some animal cells
may also have vacuole,
but not all. The best analogue of vacuole in animal cells is lysozyme.
It is here here in orange.
This is a lysozyme here.
Lysozyme,
lysozyme.
Lysozyme can be considered as a waste disposal site
in the animal cage.
Lysosomes contain enzymes, so when something comes in,
it breaks down.
The interior of the lysosomes has a relatively low pH,
it is more acidic than it is, so that things that fall into them can be broken down
and their components to be recycled.
Because we are in the category of places in which
are degraded, catabolized
or metabolize different things,
we can talk about peroxisomes too.
Peroxisomes.
Here we can see two of them,
they call it that because when they were found for
the first time, the scientists said, "Hey, there's something going on here,
oxidation reactions occur. "
"The final by-product appears to be hydrogen
peroxide. "They were called peroxisomes.
We still study all the functions these organelles perform,
but we know they are important to
breaking down long chains of fatty acids,
to make them easier to use than other parts of the cage.
Peroxisomes have other roles,
whose mechanisms are not yet fully studied.
Now let's get back to the differences between herbs and herbs
animal cells. Key difference is
these organelles here.
These are chloroplasts.
Photosynthesis takes place there
and of course, they occur in plant cells.
Thanks to these organelles the plants
they create food.
We can say that they fix carbon with the help of light energy.
Chloroplast.
We have chloroplast here.
Chloroplasts are not found in animal cells.
When we talk about energy,
we are talking about factories producing ATP in cells,
they occur in both cell types.
This of course is the mitochondria.
We see mitochondria in both cell types.
There are other organelles found in plant,
and in animal cells.
We see
Goldie apparatus in this cell
and in this.
This is where the proteins are packaged for use
in the cage itself or out of it.
We have an endoplasmic network.
We have a grainy endoplasmic mesh,
which has ribosomes associated with the membrane,
we also have a smooth endoplasmic mesh that has no ribosomes.
This is where many proteins are produced,
as well
lipids.
Then we have the nuclear shell.
In fact, this is the internal nuclear membrane
right here.
The outer membrane is connected
with the endoplasmic grid.
You can see these structures in both cell types.
In the nuclear shell, of course, there is DNA.
It is in the form of a chromatin. We also have
this very dense area, which is visible on a microscope.
It is called coyote and associates
p
robozomic forms and ribosomal RNA.
Naturally we have all these free ribosomes.
We have free ribosomes.
I would say that this is a very quick review of
eukaryotic cells,
but I hope you gave it an idea
for some of the major differences between plant and animal cells.